all right ladies and gentlemen my name
is papa
and i can't believe i'm doing this we're
playing some amnesia the dark descent
you can probably tell by this that this
is a scary game and it's supposed to be
scary as hell uh and i'm not gonna lie
like
i i can't handle the scary games i
rarely play them
probably the scariest game i've ever
come close to is bioshock and you're
probably thinking like fire shock that's
not even a scary game and yeah you're
right that's probably as far as i've
gone so
uh why don't you join me in this
adventure and laugh at me while i piss
my pants or something
something piss related it will it be at
least
that's just upside down that's weird
i knew
i hope this is not going to be like
loading forever
because i can take that
here we go
all right don't forget
some things mustn't be forgotten
the shadow hunting me i must hurry
my name is daniel i live in london i'd
had ah
mayfair
what have i done
this is crazy
don't forget
i must stop him focus
my name is
i can move
i am
daniel
that was a really interesting start is
it loading
can't move though
all right what is this
down down down down down
oh god my head i got a headache ah
sunday mornings
uh
too much jaeger oh my hey
i love the graphics they're really
awesome
tell us this
is it blood or is it rose
rose leaves or whatever it's called
yeah it's roses
yeah it
and we got the is
no news
i'm just kidding
uh a lot of people who
i don't know when they play scary games
they tend to make it in to a joke or
maybe which i think is hilarious but
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do that
because
um
i am [ __ ] scared so i'm not gonna
hide that i think it ruins kind of the
point of the game if you want to just
joke around about it all the time i
don't know
oh i should not click that
can i throw it
okay that wasn't me i'm out of here
oh god
i don't trust that juice
where's the [ __ ] is this on
get up come on get up daniel
what the [ __ ]
seriously
i don't trust you guys
[ __ ] you
can i punch him in the nuts nope
what was that
[ __ ] it's been what like 10 seconds and
i'm already scared
okay
come on i'm not a [ __ ]
just gonna head out there nothing usual
just gonna go out here and ah
okay no don't go with that door
camp in the corner
camp in the corner i'm a cod player i
know this
camp in the corner works every time
all right check the corners for campers
and a jump shot
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i hate this game
already
ah deep breath you can do this
what was that
i heard breathing was that me
tinderbox i think that
i don't trust these kind of rooms like
it looks nice but i don't know i'm not
gonna go there
i'm not gonna do that
all right
okay i might as well go in there it's
like a part of the game right
all right i can see through
uh i see you
whatever
let's just do this let's take it slowly
nice knees
check the corners
god it's so uh it's so creepy that i
can't see
i can't see this it's so dark so i mean
it scares the hell out of me that's this
is a nice room
got a nice velvet chair
okay i just should stop doing that
ah some liquor
oh
i can't pick it up
no
[ __ ] you liquor
tinderbox my head is tilting what the
hell what's up with that
all right let's keep on moving
ah it's a nice painting
i wonder what year it is
very nice
ah we read the renaissance verena is
very nice depth in this picture
and uh that cow was actually my first
lover
her name was christine and
that's not even [ __ ] funny so i don't
know why i'm saying that
all right
nice and easy
i should remember this
is what's in the cutscene right
what the [ __ ] yes oh
[ __ ] my [ __ ]
did you guys hear that
[ __ ] i'm so scared already
oh i got goosebumps seriously
[ __ ] your couch
all right nice and easy
daniel
[ __ ] [ __ ] seriously
did i just walk through here
or someone else
oh yeah
disorienting
ah take it easy
take it easy now
i got this
that's very prior normal activity over
that
i hate that movie so much
all right
no shake the corners jump shot
nope
that door did not just open itself
and we gotta share
okay let's go in here
so dark what the
what the [ __ ]
oh it was oh my [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] statue
i wasn't scared
me scared what the hell
all right like
i don't want to go in there
i guess
let me shake the corners
i'll just shake the choirs it's pretty
nice painting here i should just
holy [ __ ] no no
no no no no no
[ __ ] this game
oh that's nice
i can throw
sweet
old archives
he fell to the kitchen floor tears were
beginning to well in his eyes as he
received the first kick in his stomach
hazel remained hidden in his fear she
too would be punished
i have no idea what that meant
oh [ __ ] i just heard some someone
outside it kind of creeped me out
did you get
did you guys hear something
the [ __ ] is that sound coming from
i got a book
awesome
oh
i want to burn it
let the books hit the door
it's [ __ ] hard
there we go
all right ah [ __ ] my [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] this game camp in the corner
always camp in the corner
all right
ah [ __ ] this game
i'm gonna end part one there's